Donald Trump appears to have turned off
FoxNews literally and also turned on
FoxNews figuratively turned against them
so to speak at least weekend Fox News
and he is unleashed exactly the type of
unhinged Twitter storm that we've become
pretty used to actually as something
that the president does over the last
couple of years remember I told you
before there's nothing immutable or set
in stone about Fox News and Donald Trump
being aligned yes right now Trump mostly
is watching Fox News Trump mostly says
that Fox News is doing the right type of
reporting a fox give Trump a lot of
ideas that then Trump sees on Fox and
Friends in the morning and then tweets
about all day or talks about for a few
days on the other hand yes mostly Fox
News supports Donald Trump sometimes
Shepard Smith or Chris Wallace will say
some basic uncontroversial truth a you
know fundamental real-world critique of
Donald Trump and the Fox News audience
will be angry with them even though in
most of the world what Fox and what Shep
and Chris Wallace say is just the truth
but remember that early in the 2016
Republican primary Fox News and Donald
Trump were not actually aligned and they
only later sort of joined forces
anyway Trump is furious check out this
series of tweets and as usual imagine
Barack Obama sitting around tweeting
stuff like this it's hard to imagine
because it would never have happened
because this is unlike anything we've
ever seen before in the Oval Office
Trump tweeting quote watching Fox News
weekend anchors is worse than watching
low ratings fake news CNN or lyin Brian
Williams remember when he totally
fabricated a war story trying to make
himself into a hero and got fired a very
dishonest journalist and the crew of
degenerate Comcast NBC MSNBC Trump
haters who do whatever Brian and Steve
tell them to do like CNN NBC is also way
down in the ratings but Fox News who
failed in getting the very boring dem
debates is now loading up with Democrats
and even using fake unsourced New York
Times as a source of information ask The
Times what they paid for the Boston
Globe and what they sold it for
1.5 billion dollars or their old
headquarters building disaster or their
unfunded liability Fox News is changing
fast but they forgot the people who got
them there this thing about they forgot
the people who got them there Trump
seems to have the relationship backwards
they got Trump there by jumping on his
side about halfway through the 2016
campaign when they saw that he actually
seemed to be appealing to a shockingly
high portion of the Republican
electorate and they kind of work
together in getting Trump to where he is
today now all of this happened why it's
not really clear we don't know it
appears that it might be because Fox
News broadcast the following video of
people in France watching the Women's
World Cup final and when Fox News goes
live the crowd knows it's Fox News and
they start chanting F Trump take a look
at this video just the funniest part
about this is that if this really is why
Trump lost it on Fox News it's not
really Fox's fault I mean Fox is doing
live TV this is what people started
chanting presumably unbeknownst to the
anchor as he went live but if this makes
Trump angry with Fox great because any
disruption to Fox being a total arm of
the Trump administration status quo is
great and from continuing his bizarre
attack on Fox later on saying quote
impossible to believe that Fox News has
hired Donna Brazile the person fired by
CNN after they tried to hide the bad
facts and failed forgiving crooked
Hillary Clinton the questions to a
debate something unimaginable now she is
all over Fox including Shep Smith by far
their lowest rated show watched the Fox
News weekend daytime anchors who were
terrible go after her big time that's
what they want but it sure is not what
the audience wants I don't really know
that a super deep analysis is even
required here I mean Trump is triggered
because he expects Fox News to be proach
from Beco chambers 24/7 occasionally
sometimes even by accident
the case of that video from the World
Cup Paris F Trump chant something will
occasionally pierce the echo chamber and
Donald Trump gets mad this guy is a very
sensitive snowflake he constantly
attacks others as weak soldiers who have
PTSD are not strong enough even though
trump's dad paid a doctor to write a
letter about how trump's ankles preclude
him from going to Vietnam
totally emasculated is Trump by the mere
mention of John McCain so he makes it
his job to attack McCain endlessly and
the most important implication is that
if the relationship between Trump and
Fox News breaks as the twenty20 election
gets closer that's a really good
opportunity for something other than Fox
News to be preventing to get into the
action and maybe we can get Trump
removed from office in the sense that
anything that disrupts this kind of hand
in glove relationship between Trump and
Fox News is great and we should make
sure to publicize anytime that there is
this apparent rift when Fox News
criticizes Trump it should be widely
publicized we know Trump will hear about
it we know it will trigger him we know
it will send him into another Twitter
frenzy and anything we can do to sever
that relationship is potentially going
to pay dividends in the 2020 election
now just as a word of warning
remember if Trump moves on from Fox as
his favorite he is probably going to
move on to promoting an even crazier
channel called it I don't remember if
it's Oh a N or oann I think it's like
one American news or the one American
news network I forget exactly it's even
more off the deep end than Fox News if
you can imagine it and check it out
online if you want although you may not
be thrilled about giving them any of
your web traffic and potentially ad
revenue but if Trump does sever the tie
with Fox he's probably going to oen and
they're even wackier and Oh a n rising
in terms of prominence in the United
States would be materially destructive
to everything we hold near and dear in
terms of the fabric of this country so
there's ups and downs I don't know what
do you think is going on with the Trump
Fox relationship let me know I've told
you before that the word socialist for
the American right has become just like
a meaningless catch-all insult that
doesn't
actually have anything to do with what
socialism is as a form of government as
a form of an economy socialism is in its
simplest form a system where ownership
of the means of production is socialized
there are different versions of it we
can debate whether we should be for or
against it but socialism is socialism
it's not other stuff that you don't like
em of Iceland from TYT I hope I'm
pronouncing your last name correctly
interviewed a trump supporter and this
Trump supporter may be the dumbest Trump
supporter I have ever seen interviewed
period and that takes a lot I mean it
takes a lot to even potentially get to
that level the woman that Emma
interviews says that Joe Biden is a
socialist now of course if you look at
the Democratic field you would realize
that Joe Biden would be the likely the
furthest from the socialist of those can
that it's currently running in the
Democratic primary um and Emma asks
basic follow-up questions like what do
you mean Joe Biden's a socialist and
then it gets really good if you're
listening and not watching just bear in
mind that the woman is wearing obviously
a red maggot during the interview do you
think Joe Biden is a socialist yes how
would you define socialism I'd be fine
socially when you bring down your own
country your own race because he's not
black and I mean bringing him down to
black people so you're saying no he's
saying that the white people okay so
it's already insane he's a socialist
because he's bringing down his own
country and race and he's not black what
like what does that even mean I'm not
even understanding the language that's
being used never mind the underlying
sentence sentiment that this woman is
trying to communicate let's continue she
tries another definition and Emma is
actually so perplexed by the stupidity
of this person she's visibly struggling
to even unpack this and ask follow-up
questions because you can't unpack
complete and utter nonsense
Pete that's what I look at hey you talk
about the white people and look at you
know she actually some no I don't like
it I'll tell you exactly why I don't
like him he's got a big ego he thinks
he's better than God your trunk Trump
said he could shoot someone in the
middle of Fifth Avenue and get away with
it
no I don't think so that's fake I swear
to god you can watch him nose fake okay
this part is actually really scary Trump
obviously did say that he could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and not lose
support this is how the minds of these
people work they hear something that
they don't like they just deny it exists
and this is why you can't reason with
these people and I'm gonna say more
about that later okay do you wanna watch
the video they say I have the most loyal
people did you ever see that where I
could stand in the middle of Fifth
Avenue and shoot somebody and I wouldn't
lose any voters okay it's like
incredible any of the Democrats to any
of them appeal to you liars
Oh Liars the Pinocchio keeps growing
okay and then you yourself won't have a
country you yourself won't have a
country
keep believing all this liars and you
yourself will be out of your country
socialism doesn't work wherever it goes
why is Joe Biden a socialist why is your
by non-associative he because he saw
what about the money
I mean socialism is about know the thing
is that Joe Biden is all about the money
it's all about the power the money
that's why Trump's a billionaire yes I
saw his Joe Biden yes
Trump went bankrupt four times and
that's business but he did people okay
you go bankrupt how many people do that
start all over again after bankruptcy so
this is severe idiocy
that's all I mean this is not this is
not a person who simply mentally ill
right that's not what we're talking
about here sure there may be some
personality disorders going on there who
knows but this is someone who's simply
severely brainwashed Biden is a
socialist because he's all about the
money
and Biden is a billionaire Biden is of
course not a billionaire and if he were
a billionaire in a country where most
people can't even meet a $400 expense
that's unexpected he probably would not
be a socialist and the most important
takeaway I want you to glean from this
is that we can't convince these people
that Trump is toxic that he's bad for
the country that he's bad for the world
and not to vote for him you can't
convince these people because they
reason backwards facts have no effect on
them they come up with an idea like
Biden's a socialist and they will
attribute to that anything Biden's a
socialist because of something about his
race Biden's of socialist because he's
all about the money
Biden's a socialist because he's a
billionaire so when I say don't worry
about them I don't mean don't worry
about the fact that people like this are
what got Trump elected and have done so
much damage to this country what I mean
is let's just get left wingers to vote
it's a much better campaign strategy and
this is an example of why how long would
it take you to convince this woman to
vote for someone other than Trump would
it take five hours would it take ten
hours if we got like the most
influential and effectively convincing
progressive minds in a room with this
woman would it take a hundred hours to
convince her to vote for someone other
than Trump how many people who already
dislike Trump but are sort of on the
fence about whether they want to vote at
all could we simply talk to and say
listen here's why you should vote let's
get you registered here's why voting is
important I believe that in the time it
would take to convince this one woman to
vote for someone other than Trump if it
were even possible we could be
convincing dozens or hundreds of people
to vote for someone other than Trump who
already are sensitive to the anti-trump
ideology so as I've said before I do a
show right
I believe in dialogue Emma works for TYT
it makes sense for her to talk to this
woman I take phone calls from Trump
ist's and from right-wingers but I'm
doing a
show right as a campaign strategy as a
get-out-the-vote strategy is strategy to
defeat Donald Trump in 2020 don't waste
your time with these people because
there is no sense in it you cannot
convince them or if you could it the
amount of time it would take would not
make any sense to actually spend okay
they're a lost cause for the purposes of
winning elections the way we want to win
them let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show if you're
watching on youtube please hit the
subscribe button down below
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video okay
I regularly receive videos of
interactions with police from people in
the audience usually I don't end up
talking about them on the show because
they don't see anything interesting or
the circumstances seem very blurry
I don't blur II or a gray area maybe not
literally blurry video but just as
unclear exactly what's going on there's
nothing interesting I don't think
there's
interesting points to be made but in the
past there have been some times that we
successfully put a spotlight on
interactions between police and citizens
and a one example is back in 2015 I
received a video from Ohio of a black
man being pulled over for quote making
direct eye contact with a police officer
that clip ended up getting nearly
300,000 YouTube views but more
importantly it actually led to a meeting
between the black man and the white
officer and I believe an apology and
maybe even further training for officers
it was a really great thing that was
able to come of it I have another video
for you today and another one of these
stories that I do want to talk about and
this one is from Fairfax County Virginia
and it involves a young black man back
in March the video was only recently
made available sitting in his car at a
red light driving home from work and
before I tell you the story make sure
that you subscribe like and share this
video if you're watching it on YouTube
we want this to be widely seen that's
how it will have the widest impact so
subscribe like the video and share it as
the story has been told to me an officer
Bush badge number four zero seven seven
started following the young black man
made eye contact as the officer passed
the black man the officer then makes a
u-turn in the middle of the street to
get right behind this young man and
follows the man into his neighborhood
and all the way to his apartment
building in fact at which point the
driver parks and the officer approaches
the man and starts asking questions that
don't seem quite right given the
circumstances including claiming not to
believe that the young black man
actually lives in the apartment complex
into which they've pulled despite the
fact that as I've been told the story
there is actually a resident parking
sticker on the driver side of the
vehicle driven by the young black man
that associates it with the apartment
complex in to which they pulled so we
have video and I want to show you a
video and there's a lot of concerning
things here let's look at clip number
one hey hey sir how you doing are you
okay good hey do you live here I do yes
okay where do you live up in this
apartment right here
okay you got ID on you know I know you
know I do have an ID but after searching
you have ID on you I do have an idea
okay do you have to show it to you you
don't have to is this your car yes this
okay is there a problem
what building do you live in this
building right here what's the address
I don't decide okay I want you to
address what's that do I need to tell
you the address yeah what's the address
why don't you tell you my address I'm
asking what the address is so I don't
need to tell you that because I'm asking
you but is there a reason why you're
asking me because I want to know if you
live here because if you don't live here
- totally I do live here great but if
you don't know the address so notice
that there's a series of questions none
of which seem to have any relation to
reasonable suspicion of a crime having
been committed the driver knows his
rights and is asserting them and then it
gets to the crux of what the officer
said there it doesn't look like to me
that you live here you don't look like
you live here what would be the reason
for that what about this man who knows
his rights and has done nothing to
warrant suspicion of a crime what about
his appearance suggests to the officer
that he doesn't really live in the
apartment complex in which he claims to
live now I know that there will be
people who will say David the driver is
being obstinate just give your ID state
the address and you'll be on your way
and this is exactly the problem this is
called phishing the officer asserts no
reason why he's following and now asking
repeated questions to this individual
the driver realizes that the officer is
fishing and he doesn't provide more
information and your reaction is that
the driver is the problem here by the
way again the driver reportedly has a
parking sticker for that parking complex
that apartment complex in a window on
the driver's side but again he doesn't
have to engage with this stuff if he
doesn't want to so let's continue where
he goes back to the car questions about
the car and questions about how long the
individual has lived in the area and why
is now sweetie why is that
whose vehicle is this this is my vehicle
is it in your name I said my mom's name
is in my name also okay how long have
you lived in this area I'd have to tell
you that I'm just asking you a question
okay but why are you asking me these
questions
do you live here or not sir I already
told you I do live here okay cuz if you
don't live here you're trespassing I
know that and I told you I live here
okay so what's the address that you live
at why do I have to tell you that cuz I
don't believe you live here sir and why
don't you believe me why don't you
believe I live here cuz you don't know
the address re told you I do know the
address okay what's the address that you
live I don't have to tell you that I
live here while you harassing me okay
I'm not harassing you yeah you're in my
neighborhood coming up to me tell me ask
me what my address is cuz you say I
don't live here why don't you believe I
love you if you don't live here then
you're trespassing
do you have reason to believe that I'm
trespassing I mean again other than the
fact that you said I don't look like I'd
live here the driver doesn't have to do
the police officers job for him and good
for the driver for saying you're telling
me you don't believe I live here but why
are you even talking to me right now
these questions or questions meant to
try to trip up or create an apparent
contradiction or even just to further
make the driver nervous as the driver
understandably is as you can hear in his
voice so that he then does something
justifying further interaction with the
officer whether it's searching the car
pulling the driver out whatever and the
driver you hear the nervousness in his
voice but he doesn't take the bait and I
think that's good now this is a good
point for me to make now this is not
about messing with police okay this is
about police messing with drivers who
have done nothing wrong
that police can articulate that would
create suspicion of any kind that a
crime may have been committed by this
person I am NOT one of these folks you
see these videos on YouTube or I'm about
seeking out Border Patrol checkpoints to
refuse to provide ID or answer questions
to make interesting YouTube videos I'm
not about that I think that that's
generally a waste of time I'm not into
driving deliberately into sobriety
checkpoints and trying to interfere with
the checkpoint whatever right that's not
that's not find out to be a waste of
time that's different here that's not
what's going on this is an individual
who is just driving home when this
officer decided this is someone that I'm
going to talk to and start asking
repeated harassing questions often you
will hear well the driver generally
matched
description of someone we were looking
for police will say that that wasn't
said here and it hasn't been asserted
after the fact even though an
investigation has been opened up let's
now watch the end of the interaction sir
I'm not harassing you and I can't have
you leaving bass number you can
detective Bush and my badge number is
four zero seven seven okay thank you so
do you have an ID on you or not I do I
already told you I do you have an ID
okay what's your name I don't have to
tell you that
am I being insane am I free to go you're
free to go sir thank you have a good day
ultimately getting to the key question
am I being detained
or am I free to go detective Bush
ultimately realizes he has no business
trying to detain this person he has no
justification for detaining this
individual and the right question was
ultimately asked am i free to go and the
answer was yes this is a guy driving
around an officer decides that absent
any evidence or reason for suspicion
he's going to mess with the sky and see
what he can find
he's going fishing let me throw my
fishing line in the water and see if
there's fish because why not maybe I'll
catch something and it gets worse
because the officer stayed at the
apartment complex just watching this guy
for a while a half-hour one additional
video just 8 seconds to show you
and there's the officer continuing to
wait around in the parking lot I don't
know more about this right now okay you
now have all the information that I have
I was sent this I watched all of these
videos multiple times in detail let's
see what comes comes of this I'm told
that internal affairs is now
investigating this knowing and asserting
your rights when you were being
confronted by police for no reason is
not being obstinate and this guy did the
right thing a lot of people don't know
what their rights are in these
situations
despite being clearly nervous you hear
the agitation in the black man's voice
and I understand it he asserted his
rights he remained calm and it doesn't
always go this way there are times when
merely asserting your rights in the way
that this individual did can actually
get you pulled out of the car and can
get the vehicle searched and there is a
risk associated with this approach we'll
see what comes of it this is a police
department that whose demographics are
drastically out of line with the
demographics of the community which they
police and this is an issue that's a
much broader issue in the United States
that we've talked about before Pete
Budaj actually brought this up at the
recent Democratic presidential debate so
let me know what you think about this as
as soon as I have more information I
will give it to you because this is all
I have so far please remember to
subscribe like and share this video we
do want as many people to see it as
possible we'll take a quick break make
sure you're following the show on
instagram at david pakman show follow me
on Instagram at David Pakman as well so
this is this is very interesting I want
to take a little bit of a break from
serious politics for a second and not
that the alleged rape by Donald Trump of
a thirteen-year-old along with Jeffrey
Epstein is not serious but I want to
just take a step back and show you just
an example of Donald Trump being the
totally triggered snowflake that we know
him to be at one of his own rallies so
as you know just to very quickly sort of
reset Jeffrey Epstein has now been
arrested on really serious child sex
trafficking charges as you also may know
there are longstanding allegations
against Donald Trump and Epstein for
raping the same 13-year old girl at
Epstein's men
New York City condo years ago Trump
recently did one of his Magga alleys in
Duluth Minnesota
there was a protester in the crowd
holding up a picture of Donald Trump
with Jeffrey Epstein because again they
used to be friends they used to hang out
now I would put the picture on the
screen for you
it's a very well-known picture but the
pictures copyright is held by Getty
Images which is one of the most
aggressive bogus copyright claimants
around so I'm not going to do that but
you can easily find the picture online
if you do a google image search for
Donald Trump Jeffrey Epstein Trump is on
the right in the picture
Epstein a two Epstein's left that would
be with his arm around Jeffrey Epstein
so at Trump's Duluth Minnesota rally
this is just great a protester or an
audience member I guess you could call
them had a blown-up version of this
picture and you can see as Donald Trump
is talking he notices it and he does
kind of a double take and then he
clearly recognizes it and that's already
kind of interesting because it means
very clearly the Epstein stuff is on
Trump's mind that Trump from this far
away would instantly recognize what the
picture is of and Trump immediately
starts calling for the guy holding the
picture to be removed he interrupts his
own speech and brilliantly the fox news
feed actually showed the guy holding the
blown-up picture and the content of the
picture itself I was actually thinking
maybe this is what Trump saw over the
weekend on Fox that angered him so much
that he went on that crazy anti Fox News
Twitter storm over the weekend in any
case check out our president more than
70 years old triggered so strongly by a
picture of him with one of his friends
that he interrupts his own speech and
calls even more attention to the guy and
then obviously the 70 plus year old
billionaire president starts insulting
the guy holding the picture with red
meat for the Trump estonians joking
about the gender identity of the guy
because oh my goodness it's a guy with
long hair which obviously is what we
would make fun of let's take a look at
the video you have to mark up thousands
of miles coming through Mexico you come
up thousand
of miles coming through Mexico and we're
gonna stop it get him out of here get
him outta here
[Applause]
go home to your mom darling go home
to get them out of here out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
was that a man or a woman because he
needs a haircut more than I do
the chance of USA USA are almost fitting
in a sense
USA USA where our president is accused
of rape and sexual assault 15 times
still becomes president and then kicked
out of his speeches anybody who calls
attention to his friendly relationships
with his Co acute KOCO alleged
perpetrator I guess we would call them
the crowd chants USA as a protester is
ejected for holding up a picture of
Trump with a man he allegedly conspired
with to rape a thirteen-year-old we
don't have to read dystopian science
fiction of hundreds of years from now or
50 years from now I mean this is the
dystopia understand this is how Trump
takes back control with gender identity
jokes Trump is accused of raping a 13
year old with his friend Jeffrey Epstein
Epstein gets arrested the allegations
are horrible someone in the audience has
a picture of Trump with Epstein and
Trump gets the crowd back on his side
instead of being concerned about the
allegations
the crowd is riotous over Trump making
fun of whether it's a boy or a girl
because hey they have long hair and long
hair is for girls and the crowd goes
absolutely bonkers how funny right a boy
with long hair it's like he's a girl in
some way the President of the United
States making fun of men for having long
hair which is extra strange by the way
considering Donald Trump looks just like
his own mother and that's not I mean
it's not a joke Trump looks just like
his own mother I'm not sure if you've
seen pictures but who cares this is what
the guy in the Glass House is choosing
to throw stones about he's accused of
raping a child and someone holds up a
picture and this is how the president
behaves the world is laughing the world
is laughing and it is going to take
years if not a decade once Trump finally
is gone to rebuild the relationships
that he has embarassingly destroyed make
sure you're following me on instagram at
David Pakman where you can ask me
questions about this or any other
stories from today's show follow
show on Instagram as well at David
Pakman show so the clowns over at Fox
News are just absolutely thrilled that
we live in a country where people are
free to work multiple jobs because one
job doesn't give them a stable a
standard of living there's this concept
called freedom from versus freedom to
that exists in political philosophy and
it relates to positive and negative
freedoms okay so positive Liberty is the
freedom to do something and negative
Liberty is the freedom from being
stopped by other people from doing
something so the point is there's
different types of Liberty and sometimes
the freedom to do something is actually
only relevant because there's a lack of
freedom somewhere else so here's an
example if I say it's great to have the
freedom in the United States to work for
whichever company gives you the best
health insurance a counterpoint would be
hold on a second it's terrible to lack
the freedom in the United States to be
able to just work whatever job is the
most rewarding job without being
constrained by worrying about losing
your health insurance that's the way I
would see it okay this gets us to Fox
News now if I said to you if you look at
the numbers of people in the United
States who are working multiple jobs is
that a form of freedom to work as many
jobs as you want or is that actually a
reflection of the lack of freedom that
stagnant wages and a lack of living
wages place on people and force them
into having to work multiple jobs
I consider the working multiple jobs
thing an indicator of the lack of
freedom that too many workers in the
United States experience which gets us
to the Fox News perspective on this
issue where absolute and total farcical
clowns Pete hagseth and Ainsley Earhardt
are just gushing they're literally
thanking God about how wonderful it is
that we live in a country where people
can work multiple jobs and it's it's
mind-blowing that this is actually an
analysis that resonates with millions of
people in this country take a look you
know you know what Connell Harris says
is so it's so disingenuous for most of
my life I've worked two or three or four
types of jobs of sources of income
today you can do that more flexibly how
many people do you know who do something
and then maybe in their free time they
drive an uber or they do something else
to bring an extra cash thank God we live
in the kind of country where we have the
innovation and flexibility where you can
bring in money from different things
when I'm in an uber and you talk to them
you get to know on many of them do say
they're doing this to make a little
extra money and we start talking about
how much extra do you mind if I ask do
you make a week and it's it's enough to
pay for their kids to take an extra swim
class this one guy told me or it's
enough to put a little bit of money
aside for their kids to go to college I
love those types of people my dad worked
several jobs if you had the opportunity
make a little extra he would these
people are truly sick I mean it's it's
not inspiring that so many people have
to work second jobs and third jobs it
would be inspiring to live in a country
where people didn't have to do that
right this is like those supposedly
heartwarming inspirational stories about
how great Americans are because when
Little Jimmy needed a prosthetic leg
because of a medical condition
Jimmy's classmates and teachers came
together to fundraise and do bake sales
to raise money what a great country
no no it's disgusting that one of the
richest countries in the world makes the
reality one where Jimmy couldn't just
get the prosthetic leg and needed money
from his classmates and from teachers
and from the parents of classmates
buying muffins at a bake sale it's
backwards
okay and I actually want to go further
this multiple job status quo that's so
common actually reinforces the system we
have I've talked about this in my
segments about types of activism that go
beyond just signing a petition or
calling your elected official I've said
before corporations have huge
disproportionate control over our
systems the legal system the judicial
system media everything they maintain
control in part by making sure that
there's a system in which the average
person doesn't go protest doesn't demand
change doesn't participate in strategic
defaults or mass rallies in urban
centers and one of the best ways to make
sure people don't do that that people
don't protest and people don't demand
change
is if they can't even miss a day of work
because that would be two or three jobs
that they might get fired from or they
can't miss a day of work because they
can't buy food if they miss that day of
work that's a really great way to make
sure people don't show up and actually
protest and demand real change and if
you're in a situation where you even
need multiple jobs then you are very
unlikely to have the wherewithal and
resources to go in protest and demand
changes to the system that caused you to
need two or three jobs in the first
place this is a self-reinforcing
feedback loop and I mean listen I don't
know the Fox News hosts who said it's
just so inspiring to live in a country
thank God we live in a country where
people can work ten jobs if that's what
they want to do they may be useful
idiots they may be actual cogs in the
wheel deliberately reinforcing the
system it doesn't really matter okay the
effect is that they are reinforcing the
system that big corporations have
already done a pretty damn good job at
reinforcing really disturbing and
disgusting stuff you might remember or
you might not because corporate media
basically hasn't covered this which is
that Donald Trump has been accused not
just of sexually assaulting more than a
dozen adult women but of raping a
thirteen-year-old girl and I've told you
before that this event allegedly took
place along with one of Donald Trump's I
don't know if we call him an associate
or an acquaintance or a friend but it's
a guy named Jeffrey Epstein a woman
known only as Jane Doe previously had
alleged that when she was 13 years old
Donald Trump raped her at a party thrown
by Jeffrey Epstein and that Epstein
himself had also raped her now the woman
ended up fearing for her life and
dropping a civil suit against Donald
Trump but of course the allegations
themselves have not been recanted
Epstein has been sort of a slippery guy
to actually charge of with some of these
incidents but he has now been arrested
and charged with sex trafficking dating
back to the early 2000s he is now facing
charges for paying underage girls for
massages and molesting them in Florida
and New York homes that he owns
and before we even get to the Trump
connection because that's a whole other
thing I have to tell you that the right
is spreading endless lies already about
Epstein one example is the right is
saying the Robert Moeller FBI allowed
Epstein to plead to lesser charges and
avoid a long jail sentence the truth is
that the deal Epstein previously got
four charges was from the then Miami US
Attorney Alexander Acosta who happens to
be Trump's labor secretary now this is
now really bad the records say Epstein
brought 40 girls who were underage to
his Florida mansion and they were sold
into sexual encounters of all kinds
these allegations are truly disgusting
and disturbing and then the Trump piece
pops up Trump said about Jeffrey Epstein
to New York magazine in 2002 quote I've
known Jeff for 15 years terrific guy
he's a lot of fun to be with it is even
said that he likes beautiful women as
much as I do and many of them are on the
younger side not good not good so back
to the allegations that Donald Trump
raped one of the same girls that Epstein
allegedly raped when she was 13 at
Epstein's Manhattan condo I don't know
if they're going to resurface here as a
result of this arrest but this is
certainly not what Donald Trump would
consider to be good news to have Jeffrey
Epstein the back in the public spotlight
in this way now I've looked at the
content of the lawsuit that again was
filed against Donald Trump for the rape
the charges were eventually dropped
supposedly because of death threats
against the accuser it is shocking what
is in the the lawsuit I'm not going to
read it to you it's dozens of pages but
you can easily find it online and we're
going to link to it on YouTube the
accuser claimed before the lawsuit was
withdrawn just as a few highlights that
Trump threatened her to never talk about
the rape or she risked being hurt or
killed which is exactly in line with the
intimidatory tactics that we know Donald
Trump has employed against such former
mistresses as stormy Daniels so it's all
truly sick I mean it really makes me
sick and much like with much of what's
going on with Donald Trump there may
never be consequences but with Epstein
back in the news we will see and
consider the number of conflicts that
are involved here Donald Trump is or was
friends with Jeffrey Epstein the old
prosecutor from Miami is now Trump's
labor secretary Attorney General William
bar has recused himself from the entire
Jeffrey Epstein case because his former
law firm once represented Epstein this
is another reminder of the incestuous
nature of power influence and wealth in
this country and Donald Trump knows that
this is not good for him and he actually
is on tilt next I want to talk about
what he did at a rally to someone who
held up a picture of him with Jeffrey
Epstein so it literally rained on
Trump's parade over the weekend I
totally checked out of news and politics
starting like right after we finished
the July 3rd show didn't pay attention
to anything until last night when I
started preparing for today's show but I
did hear from friends that it rained and
it poured during Donald Trump's very
absurd kind of diss dictator asked
military parade involving tanks and so
many other things but the real hilarity
was actually in Donald Trump's speech
where he said lots of things that just
made no sense whatsoever this is just
the funniest dumbest thing which tells
us that Donald Trump is ignorant not
just on the big stuff relationships
between countries and issues of foreign
policy and trade and economics and
social issues and on and on and on and
on he's also ignorant just about basic
human timelines in a sense Donald Trump
in his speech meant to I guess be
inspiring
called the salute to America on the 4th
of July
mentioned the heroic Continental Army
taking over yes airports during the
Revolutionary War for independence from
England and of course there were no
planes or airports in the 1700s but that
I guess doesn't really matter check this
out and the explanation which I'll play
for you later is even funnier the
Continental Army suffered a bitter
winter of Valley Forge found glory
across the waters of the Delaware
and seized victory from Cornwallis of
Yorktown our army man the air it ran the
ramparts it took over the airports it
did everything it had to do and at Fort
McHenry yeah what on earth is this guy
talking about airports in the 1700s I
received a really funny email about this
from Gordon Gordon said dear David I'm a
325 year-old air traffic controller and
I wish to protest that nobody told me
that there was a job for me at any of
the multitudes of airports in the USA in
the 18th century in order to make ends
meet I was forced to drive a tank at the
Battle of Yorktown whilst my brethren
through soot flew supersonic jet
fighters from the nearby nuclear-powered
aircraft carrier if I had known about
these airports I would have jumped into
my Tesla to get to the ATCO recruitment
office in Trump Tower
best wishes Gordon Bain so the the
explanation from the Trump
administration is that the teleprompter
was faulty for a moment now that's funny
because that could mean two different
things are they saying that a faulty
teleprompter incorrectly added a line
about Revolutionary War era airports
that would be a weird thing like
normally when things glitch they don't
put up coherent language that points to
in accurate historical assertions that
would be a weird sort of glitch for a
teleprompter the other explanation is
the teleprompter glitched in the sense
that Trump had to ad-lib briefly and
what Trump ad-libbed was that there were
airports in the Revolutionary War
another really strange moment was where
Trump was praising American inventors
and he mentioned the Scottish born
Canadian citizen inventor Alexander
Graham Bell check this out our quest for
greatness unleashed a culture of
discovery that led Thomas Edison to
imagine his lightbulb Alexander Graham
Bell to create the telephone the Wright
brothers to look to the sky and see the
next great frontier for Americans
nothing is impossible
so really strange to talk about how
great Americans are at inventing stuff
on the 4th of July
and mention Alexander Graham Bell who of
course was Scottish and moved to Canada
where he was a citizen when he invented
the telephone again this did not seem to
be a teleprompter glitch it actually
seemed to be part of the script or
Donald Trump ad libbing himself both of
which raised a number of questions
another embarrassment and as a reminder
because so much of this is related to
teleprompters failing or Trump reading
strange things from the teleprompter
remember what Donald Trump thought about
Barack Obama's use of a teleprompter one
example from 2012 when Donald Trump
tweeted why does Barack Obama always
have to rely on teleprompter on
teleprompters many other such examples
of course Donald Trump the guy in the
glass house throwing stones his
teleprompter reportedly glitching and
suddenly Trump thinks there were
airplanes and airports in the 17th
hundreds here's Donald Trump blaming the
teleprompter give a little appreciation
the media generally speaking loved it
they loved the evening we had a lot of
rain I stood in the rain the
teleprompter went out so ad
yeah the teleprompter went out it kept
going on and then at the end it just
went out it went kaput so I could have
said and actually right in the middle of
that sentence it went out that's not a
good feeling this guy is just the
funniest there's and he despite himself
Trump if it weren't so embarrassing
internationally day after day after day
he has no fun Ferg for a guy with no
sense of humor whatsoever he is
inadvertently funny in ways that he
can't even understand a president should
not get so confused by a teleprompter
going out that he starts saying there
were airports in the 1700s right is it
is it too much to just expect some basic
knowledge if well the prompter went out
and Trump mentioned that the Civil War
was ultimately decided by who had the
better internet technology would we
accept that and say the teleprompter
went out of course he said the internet
technology at the time determined the
winner of the Civil War no we wouldn't
accept it and this is just as stupid